il n'y a plus de vitres plus
d'électricité les faux plafonds se sont
effondrés l'hôpital saint-georges dans
le quartier d'achraf liés a été mis ko
par la double explosion de mardi dernier
tous les internes tous les infirmiers
ils sont montés ils ont fait répertorier
les malades qu'ils étaient encore
vivants et maisons des 102 avec leurs
mains des fois avec mes droits des fois
avec des brancards pamela perdu quatre
de ses collègues infirmières ce soir là
mais pas son sang froid
elle avait une seule idée en tête
s'assurer que les trois petits
nourrisson à sa charge était toujours en
vie dans leur incubateur et les sauver
les autres et vous j'avais peur de les
échappés alors je touchais leur tête
comme ça pas vérifié qu'ils étaient
toujours là un deux trois jeux les
comptes est sans arrêt
à l'hôpital de l'université américaine
de beyrouth le calme relatif est de
retour le centre hospitalier de pointe a
été submergé de blessés mardi plus de
400 quelques heures mais ils étaient
prêts nous raconte le directeur du
service des urgences
on avait deux à trois patients dans sa
chambre et dans cette région ici que
vous voyez il n'y avait plus de
d'une trentaine il y avait plus d'une
trentaine d'ici jusqu'à la porte alors
c'était comme ça partout il faut dire
que le liban a vécu des décennies de
conflits et d'attentats pour se préparer
aux situations extrêmes
on aura beaucoup d'explosions au liban
depuis la guerre civile
75 à 90 et puis les explosions des
assassinats des mais on n'a jamais vu un
d'une exclusion de ce calibre une
quinzaine de patients sont toujours aux
soins intensifs à l'hôpital comme tout
le système de santé libanais mettra du
temps à se remettre complètement
lui qui était déjà lourdement affecté
par la crise économique
et l'épidémie de comme un virus on
essaye de sauver le patient
et on se on a en plus fait pas son
attention à soi même donc je crois que
dans les semaines prochaines
on va voir un seul dont les nombres de
kobe de pêcheurs au cours des dernières
24 heures le liban a enregistré 2 179
nouveaux cas de vide 19 un retard
inquiétant
qu'est ce qu'on va faire comment on va
être payé après est-ce que l'hôpital va
pouvoir
aux fonctionnaires plein de points
d'interrogation plein plein on essaie de
ne pas y réfléchir maintenant être
continuer ce qu'il a à faire est de
rester positif ici on essaie de ne pas
trop penser aux causes de la catastrophe
on préfère ravaler sa colère et se
remettre au travail le plus vite
possible ici marie-eve bédard
radio-canada beyrouth